yeah next bull or bear sex robots um
where do i put the thing my cleaning
ladies
i mean dude my clean lady is pretty
tolerant you know i occasionally walk
around the place in my underpants but i
think she'd draw the line in a sex robot
the great thing about those scandinavian
countries i mean thinking about it the
climate
uh you know there are too many trees but
the one upside
is that everything's thought out i don't
like porn actually very much i mean
i can't claim that i don't watch it ever
because that'd be ridiculous everybody's
had a look but i found the bits of porn
where no sex is taking place
vaguely interesting because here you can
see the mental workings of someone who
has to contrive a backstory okay
and that's narrative and it's
interesting the actual act itself is
actually
unbelievably repetitive and tedious
being in a restaurant qr code menus
as absolutely unnecessary level of
complexity
what restaurant has ever given you a
menu that's two inches wide and four
inches deep
what do you think of tick-tock it's a
thing
i don't fully understand there's certain
things i always
get confused because i generally try and
make an effort to understand
um most things and
i don't find it that hard to understand
things that other people find baffling
like
trump voting and i always argue very
simply about trump voting okay
look at it like this okay imagine you
work for a company
and you can choose between two bosses
one of whom is slightly uncompetent you
know borderline alcoholics say
but really likes you and another person
who's highly confident and technocratic
but you suspect secretly despises you
okay
you're gonna vote for the first guy okay
simple as that now that's absolutely
that's absolutely incomprehensible
to people in the technocratic elite
because they've always had you know
since i don't know
clinton they've had highly academic kind
of technocratic ivy league
professors who they see as essentially
one of them
so the whole behavior is
incomprehensible tip top
to me it makes totally perfect sense uh
there are a few things i find hard to
understand
tick tock i i think i understand
um it's um it's essentially video
twitter isn't it i mean
you know but the music aspect of it i
think is really
really interesting because everybody i
think wants to make a music video of
their own life
and by making it really easy and
manageable so it's always interesting to
look at things like twitter and tech
talk through the lens of choice
reduction or facebook for that matter
in that myspace gave you too much choice
and people felt okay i've got too much
control over length of content style of
content
i'm not a graphic designer my page is
going to end up looking like
[ __ ] and then facebook comes along and
basically imposes some sort of
aesthetic constraint on you so there's a
limit to the number of variables you
have to agonize over
and twitter undoubtedly did that um
facebook did it
relative to myspace and i think tick
tock does that in
in in a different form uh by enabling
music
um but in a way that you can't [ __ ] up
um so i think i i i think there's
something going on there and
a very interesting exercise and choice
reduction by the way
go online and try and buy a jaguar eye
pace
and compare it to the choice
architecture for the ford
machine the mustang machi or the tesla
now interestingly for products that are
designed to be bought online
you don't want a huge amount of
customization
why because because
this is a bit like the paradox of choice
it is the paradox of choice
uh conventional logic says that the more
choice you have the greater the chance
you have of optimizing your own utility
your own expected utility therefore the
happier you should be
actually if you give people too many
customization options they will almost
end up almost certainly end up being
unhappy with an element of their choice
so the jaguar one for example i went in
and just as an exercise i put in the top
of the range base model
and then three pages later i found
myself asked the question well i wanted
to pay 190 pounds for fog lamps
and i kind of went i'm paying 70 000 for
a car i'm not going to
[ __ ] pay that you know 100 and
the price of the fog lamps was
immaterial it was the fact that i was
being made to pay for them
and eventually i became so resentful
at the level of kind of uh addition now
if you go to the tesla or the ford
process
it's basically five colors two kinds of
wheels two drive trains
you know i think with a tesla you can
pay a thousand for the extra interior
with the model y i think you pay a bit
extra if you want the third row of seats
well fair enough
it's a degree of complexity i'm not
grumbling about that
but the extent to which the choice is
enough to make you feel you're actually
getting what you want and not paying for
things you don't want
but at the same time it's manageable
enough that you can actually go through
it in a sequential
process without feeling some sense of
sort of seething confusion or resentment
develop tick-tock by constraining those
those guard rails is helping people to
be less
[ __ ] there's only certain degrees of
freedom that you have and by reducing
that
the the maximum amount of shitness that
your content can be has been brought
down
you've got it exactly yeah perfect we've
broken it we understand it yeah
yeah and it's always worth that probably
50 percent of my
obsession which is why i'm such a big
believer in this ergodicity debate
which is all about the mathematics of
optimization
under multiplicative dynamics okay right
okay but a very simple way of looking at
it right okay
you've got a little formula that says
one plus three one plus three is four or
two plus two
or four plus naught okay right they all
add up to four
and you can add one to either the one or
the three well it doesn't make any
[ __ ] difference
right you can add the one to the one or
you can add the one to the three and
it'll now be five
all right but under multiplicative
dynamics obviously that's not the same
rule right
you add the one to the lower of the two
numbers because if you take
obviously if you have four times naught
and you add one till to four you still
have
naught right what you want to do is add
it to
let's say three times one you want to
add the one to the two
because that way you get six okay rather
than say
naught or five or something right
now the reason that makes a difference
is that under multiplicative dynamics
and lots and lots of things in
human life are kind of more like
multiplication than they are addition
it strikes me as an essential absurd
um assumption of economics to assume
that utility is additive
okay that you utility arises from a
simple series of additive processes
that net out strikes me as bonkers look
at reputation you know the joke that
ends you shag one sheep
right okay we all know that joke okay
you know but do they call me dimitri the
boat builder
but do they call me dimitri that's
church builder but do they call me
dimitri the philanthropist
you shag one sheep right now that shows
that reputation is sort of
multiplicative
if you hit a big fat zero and one nobody
nobody nets out jimmy savile do they
nobody goes
yeah bit of a killing fiddler but on the
upside he did do a lot of work for
charity did some great work as a
philanthropist he did some great work
you know no you don't
nobody nets
[Laughter]
there's lots of things in life are
patently more like multiplication over
time than they are addition
yeah so i'm in dubai and i've misplaced
my passport
i fly home this sunday i found it this
morning
but is it not stupid that i still need a
physical paper object
in my bag to move between countries i
could rfid it we could facial
recognition
it i could fingerprint it
um interesting my own favorite solution
would be a weirdly british fudge which
is you can retain a a physical passport
for
reassurance purposes um and that you
probably take it with you but you would
also retain some other
um uh you know that in other words
passport-free travel
might be possible
but there is an element to the physical
if you think about it which is
on one very simple level what happens if
your computer system goes down and
immigration right
okay so there are you know there are
really really you know
uh simple value but i think there's also
a value to print
in kinds of ways that we don't
anticipate so i'll give you an example
of this right
if you get into a taxi in dubai or
anywhere else in the world
and it says tariff and it tells you what
the prices of taxis are different times
of the day
and it's on a bit of paper that's
laminated and stuck behind the taxi
driver's back
as it were i've got a reasonable amount
of confidence that that's the price he
charges everybody
because patently he doesn't get out of
the cab every time a new passenger gets
in
and replace the tariff according to the
expected wealth of the passenger
okay now if you have the price displayed
on a digital screen
i've got the slight and not unwarranted
fear
okay
i mean i'll give you a lovely example if
you had a digital screen
how do i know he isn't applying the
gringo
tourist tariff five-star hotel tariff
yeah
yeah well i i had that actually going to
a five-star hotel in seville
um actually this was a i think this was
a paper tower if not
no actually there was no display tariff
i think but
suddenly this guy invents a 20 euro
supplemento hero puerto
which i'm pretty sure didn't [ __ ]
exist because nobody else i met had paid
this thing
but he simply realized that i'm staying
at this hotel uh i'm almost certainly
not paying for the hotel because i'm
traveling on my own
therefore i'm not gonna risk getting
beaten up to save wpp shareholders 20
euros
so eventually i paid his [ __ ]
supplementary puerto and i went into the
hotel
there's things like paper which are kind
of set in stone
you know um the other thing is that
it you've got to remember that if you
wanted to fake something
in paper you can do it you can fake a
passport
but you can't fake passports at massive
scale
where there's possible some huge i.t
break-in would allow you know it would
suddenly allow two million people to get
fake rights to travel to the uk
this is the same argument as to why uh
polls why the american election is still
done on paper right
uh yeah you should do it on paper and
incidentally
i think the growth of postal voting is
completely unacceptable i'm with i'm
with
the donald there because when i was a
kid in the uk
you had postal voting but it was
basically confined to people serving
overseas in the military
it wasn't because i was on holiday right
or people who are bedridden
in other words you'd ask for a postal
vote in the most exceptional
circumstances
you know i can remember driving very old
people to
the polling station uh on polling day
uh in you know actually this is with my
parents driving you know when i was kind
of 10 or something
they'd drive people who needed a lift to
the polling station right
now this business of a um
there all sorts of things you can
register other people once you've done
that
if you've helped someone register to
vote uh
if you're a member of a political party
uh you then enjoy something called
reciprocation bias which is
given that these people filled in the
paperwork for me i'd feel like a bit of
a [ __ ] not voting for them
there's the possibility of coercion
within households where the dad
or someone else basically gathers up all
the votes and votes collectively
okay uh there's the possibility simply
of non-privacy
that you could in a coercive
relationship demand to see how the other
person has voted
um and there's also the possibility of
fraud at scale
uh which let's face it the americans
don't have a perfect record of that and
that jfk didn't deserve to be elected in
1959 i don't think
i mean that you know there was a whole
load of ballot stuffing in chicago and
places
and um uh i i think that it's not
it's not merely essential for the
process to be honest it needs to be seen
to be honest
because the real point of uh the real
part of democracy is not
that you get a consensus on what
government you want it's that people
arrive at consensus
a sincere belief about what everybody
else wants right
you know it's not it's not a simple
matter of aggregating preferences
it's getting the effective consensus
of everybody that this is the collective
decision
writ lodge and the second you start
having weird electronic things and the
second you start to have postal voting
i think that disappears and i think it's
highly dangerous
and we're seeing that now right we're
seeing the fall out of that now yeah so
actually oddly although i totally
i i you know i think the result is
genuine i think by one i'm not i'm not
necessarily i'm not necessarily
disputing that
i think for the longer term this
practice of widespread postal voting
um is getting a bit concerning i'd agree
also also you could argue that this is a
decision
okay which merits a walk
by maybe it's five minutes i'm not
saying it's three hours standing in a
queue and all that kind of [ __ ] goes on
where there's
you know effectively voter suppression
and that's going to be clamped on as
well
but this is a decision where i think it
just merits a walk
right to make it a bit serious okay
this isn't like voting for [ __ ] x
factor or
cake world or don skit
or whatever these flaming programs are
it's a bit more serious than that
and i think you should just get off your
ass put some clothes on
and go for a [ __ ] walk you want
something you want some rituals some
symbolism behind
it pilgrimage make a pilgrimage to the
voting booth just just say this is
slightly unusual
you know this isn't just and you know
they're i mean you know
um it's a really really important point
i think that um
uh that business of voting at home is
not really the same
because have you actually thought about
it i mean the point about the walk
and this is the slightly you know one
slight downside over
zoom versus business travel although i'm
a huge zoom advocate
is that when you travel to a meeting you
did have an hour to think about the
meeting while you're in transit
and sometimes now you find yourself
teleported into a meeting from a
different continent
with like one minute to prepare and so
you know i mean that's that's another
point i'd make which is i just think the
walk is good
again you know it says okay i'm going
here i'm making a tolerable degree of
effort
um uh you know i'm not just gonna
basically chicken
tick a box and get it over with and i
think it deserves that level of
solemnity that's that's what i'd say
give me your thoughts on dyson
airblade hand drives versus paper towels
oddly i quite like the airblade i mean i
don't know whether they've been turned
off because they're massive virus
spreaders i don't know what the effect
is
they're just atomizing whatever was on
your hands aren't they and just
pushing it as particulates into the air
um i think i never thought of it like
that but you're obviously right and they
do a good job of drying your hands in
fairness i mean that that insight that
actually
you use sort of vortices and highly
intense airflow
uh as the device seems to be quite good
it also strikes me as
what i really want to understand and
there is a podcast about this
is how you break into that bathroom
market
so did they attack paper towels did they
attack the existing dryers
because the installed base of the
berkeley illinois
world dryer corporation you know those
things where you can with a twisty
nozzle at the front
also do your hair as well for some
reason yeah yeah
well it's the dyson's you can also do
your genitals don't you if you need to
dry your genitals
uh so you know it's it's horses but
you'd have to you'd somehow have to
slide it sideways yeah you'd have to get
in sideways wouldn't you
horrible
but actually suddenly enough the dice um
one thing with
um which is a use of a hairdryer is
about
one time in a hundred when you have to
give a talk
and you have a minor chino accident when
going to the lube
before your talk which is by the way the
most frightening bit of public speaking
and i had that happen once only once and
the dryer was totally unsuited
now in fact it wasn't even a urine
related accident it was a it was a wash
basin related accident
where the wash basin catapulted load of
water into my groin
okay and i was left having to go on
stage in about five minutes
and there was a glorious natural
solution which is when i came out of the
loo in a total state wondering what to
do
like whether to turn my cardigan into a
mini dress or something
it actually started pouring with rain so
i simply went outside the hotel stood in
the rain for five minutes so i was all
over soaked
and then went back in again so i got
away with it that wasn't even urine
related i hated to do it it was very
very fortunate from you but that is one
of the that is one of the public
speakers greatest fears
the final the final urination prior to
speaking making sure that there's no
dribble
making sure that there's no aggressive
bathroom tap
that's why there are no public speakers
over 60 i suspect
that prostate's going what are your um
what are your views
on the numbers on credit cards
oh i've made those fairly explicit
that's an extraordinary design failure
with one exception actually i'll i'll
i'll give america
actually i won't share my card because
then someone will nick thing
with the exception of american express
who now
sometimes print the number in big on the
back so it's readable
okay they have a four-digit cvv which is
actually
uh properly printed on the front not in
some blurry ink on the signatures
dreb okay with the exception of american
express
credit cards were never really designed
for the number to be read out at all
because when they first came out it was
the rumble strip
okay and the fact that very few
designers have rethought the design of
the card so the number is tolerably easy
to read
and the cvv number doesn't um basically
blur off if you've ever been in a
slightly sweaty climate
and you've just carried a credit card in
your shirt pocket the chance of the cvv
number remaining legible is minuscule
and the the shiny things wear off a
credit card
so that at some occasions you have to
hold it at a strange angle to a bright
light
to have any chance of reading it but
actually one of the weird things about
design is that one of the cases where
functionalism loses out to aesthetics
is undoubtedly caused by the fact that
most designers are 20
i i just to be clear about this i really
venerate design
and designers so i'm not having a go but
most designers are 27 years old
and they're working with something like
a 38 inch 4k
monitor okay on their desk
and what looks good on that is not
necessarily readable in the real world
because you know i mean okay i mean i i
actually have to leave
this pair of reading glasses um
on my desk at all times because if i
need to read a credit card number or if
i need to read a ready meal
ready meal um recipe instructions you
know
cooking instructions are unbelievably
bad i mean you
as i said on twitter i think you know
you need an arc light in the jungle bank
telescope to have a chance of actually
reading them
and you know and so these little things
about usability in everyday life the don
norman you know to be honest i i vote
for
don norman um he's still alive he's
about 80.
but i'd vote for don norman for
president because i think a four-year
term
where the government was entirely
dedicated to improving the design of
every day
of everyday activities and everyday
things would would have been
something that that's denmark isn't it
the great thing about those scandinavian
countries i mean thinking about it the
climate [ __ ]
uh you know um you know they're too many
[ __ ] trees
but the one upside is that everything's
thought out
you know copenhagen airport you don't
have a single moment of anxiety or
confusion
you know and i i think that's why
they're so happy with large degrees of
socialism really
which is you don't mind paying a lot for
government services if they're really
competent
fair point talib says that social
sciences are bollocks and unfalsifiable
and yet your career is being built on
behavioral psychology insights
and yet you two are good friends how's
that work
okay i think social science is uh
um an area of inquiry not an area for
laying down rules okay
the value i see to social science is
largely
that by having a far wider
uh a far wider
how would i describe it um
gamut of possible causal explanations
for behavior if you think about it
economics has this one which it calls
utility and then you say what's utility
and they say it's the thing that people
try to maximize and you say what are
people trying to maximize
their own expected utility and you go
well hold on that's completely circular
logic you might as well just say
people do what people do okay now
by actually trying to understand both in
the lens of complexity theory
um and with a wider conception of human
motivation
trying to understand why people do the
things they do the most valuable
contribution of social science will
never be the contribution of
laws
like physics i'm always pleased as a
replication crisis because i said
you'd never expect this [ __ ] to
replicate all the time anyway
i've been business long enough to know
that something that works in one context
doesn't work in another
right but you increase the solution
space
inordinately if you allow a greater
range of possible explanations
into your into your model of human
behavior
and i'd argue that it's actually um
some matt ridley told me this biology
someone said is this
a science of exceptions and i think
social science is fine if you treat it
as a science of exceptions
everybody thinks that but maybe it ain't
so okay
and also um it's a science of high
levels of ambiguity by the way
because in one context people will do
one thing in a slightly different
context they'll behave completely
differently
and understanding that is just um
science in terms of a form of inquiry
and also science which is non-normative
because what talent gets annoyed with is
saying economic logic
says people should do this a lot of
people are doing that
therefore the people are wrong and we
should nudge them to a point where they
become more consistent with economic
uh theory okay that's what gets talib
angry
my view to be absolutely honest is
mostly the opposite which is
if people mostly do x after uh a million
years or so of evolution
and economics thinks they should be
doing why it's highly likely there's
something wrong with economics
right as john k who is himself an
economist says
you know it's highly unlikely that the
human
approach to for example risk or the
human approach to ergodicity and
decision-making he said as john k said
it's highly likely we would have evolved
to a state where we got it
a bit you know nearly right but not
quite right is it
it's if everybody is involved with one
leg shorter than the other right
the the idea that they're these
persistent irrationalities and that you
continue to define them as
irrationalities
is too comfortable an assumption you're
too
you're giving your model far too much
credence
if you start blaming the person before
you start blaming the model
i like it and so so i i have this
discussion very simple discussion okay
which is um uh how do you get younger
people to take out pensions
and i said yeah there are loads of ways
you can get younger people to save more
and i said
a probably don't call it a pension
because they associate it with
you know someone actually they don't
associate with a 55 year old they're
associated with a 70 year old
right but b when young people if you
want
to pay into a pension the first amount
has to be recoverable
you don't know enough about the future
to say well that money i won't be
needing that until i'm 55. no one aged
23 can say that
okay christ knows what could happen you
know anything could happen
but the second thing i said is i said
yeah you could definitely improve
the rate to which young people save in
pensions and then
the second thing i said is but never
expect the amount young people save in
pensions
the amount the economists think they
should save in pensions
and they said why is that i said because
when you're 27
finding a high quality life partner is
probably more important
than saving for retirement and i said
i'm willing to bet
if you go on tinder okay there's nobody
under 50 on tinder talking about their
pension
right are there people over 50 talking
about their pension on tinder
i would guess if you're 70 and you're
trying to pull a 58 year old
it might be you put your pension in your
bio
yeah it might be i had no clue
you know i got married before the stuff
came along yeah but
you might you know i don't know if you
you know if you're trying to pull a
spring chicken of 62
and you were 71. maybe maybe you would
talk about it i got um
i got a really interesting insight from
rob henderson on this show
he taught me a few very very fun things
about tinder first thing being that
you can 10x your popularity on tinder in
terms of right swipes
by putting a masters level education as
opposed to a bachelor's level education
in your bio if you're a man
and the 80 20 pareto principal also
works on tinder
the bottom 80 of men are competing for
the bottom 20 percent of women
and the top 80 of women are competing
for the top 20
of men that's out of datanomics which is
a data science
uh analysis done of dating trends
it's a horrible thing to say but most of
a lot of what is nasty in society
um like excessive consumerism and you
know excessive spend on luxury guns and
signaling
could probably be reduced if women were
actually less selective about who they
slept
with sadly look girls just just dropped
the standards a little bit and
everything
will be fine right we're going to play
rory we're going to play a game
we're going to play a game
this was a pretty rich guy um
he said apart from the very funny joke
when um
uh somebody asked a russian what would
have happened if
uh uh mr khrushchev had been shot
instead of mr kennedy
and the russian replied i don't think
aristotle and nasus would have married
mrs
um but um apart from that joke nasus
actually said he said if there were no
women in the
world all the money would be worthless
um and so there's there's elements
so it's totally 80 20 that you said that
essentially
the 80 of of least desirable men
are competing for the 20 of least
desirable women
yeah and then the converse as well which
is just
i mean hypergamy is a hell of a drug
that's incredibly extreme but it's
plausible it's totally plausible
yeah and then the other the other thing
is but master's degree pays off for men
but not for women
yeah because women are signaling off
they very few women want to date a man
who is not richer than them and
uh sorry or not more educated than them
they'll take a man who's perhaps not as
rich as them
if he's incredibly clever and that's
presumably
working on a trajectory being a hedge
fund manager married to a university
professor female hedge fund manager
marriage of male university professor
or novelist if he's reasonably
successful
you know and tolerably successful or
artists
would be okay okay um
whereas it'd be much more difficult if
you were doing a less it's got to be
some degree of scarcity signaling
and actually the extent to which we use
the educational system to
signal our possession of scarce
resources
is one of the biggest grotesqueries uh
in 21st century life
so the university the higher education
has become a luxury goods industry
essentially it's prada you know it's uh
you know it's ferrari
it's horrible i mean i know that's i
know that seems weird but when i went to
university
i did you know i saw it as something to
do because i was quite interested in
[ __ ]
i didn't know but i i genuinely said
this okay this is at cambridge
university in 1987
no one discussed what job they wanted to
do until the third year
the third year beginning of the third
year you actually had to put in some
applications for [ __ ] nobody discussed
that [ __ ] at all yeah one and two
nobody was talking about i didn't know
if someone had said i want to work in
banking i go why do you want to sit
behind the glass screen with a [ __ ]
pen on a chain
right no but this is 19 this is not this
is this is less than a lifetime ago
okay now okay you know we acknowledge
the fact that if you went to you know
oxbridge or you went to a russell group
university
your employment certainly you you
thought that your chances of being
unemployed were quite low
that was certainly true in the late 80s
but there wasn't this hyper competition
that was going on nobody said you know
an m phil is the new
you know is the new ba it's just a
pulling strategy that's all it is it's
just
it's just a dating strategy get your
revenue up
up your tinder rating fine yes this is
kind of scary isn't it
yeah right we're going to play rory
we're going to play are men
bothered that much about the educational
level of women until the same extent
so it does all the earnings it doesn't
look that way no
um a man the problem is right that women
are the gatekeepers to sex
men are always going to be the sexual
protagonists and
given that for the most we all have that
friend who would take whatever he can
get
and i think that that kind of shows out
in more than just physical
characteristics as well
plus there's a classic dynamic of
resource acquisition and
kind of resource giver from the male
side right
it's very rare to find a man who wants
despite what my instagram bio says not
many men want to be a trophy husband
um it just seems emasculating and
all the rest of it right we're going to
play a game rory we're going to play a
game it's called
bull or bear and you're going i'm going
to give you
some different things and you're going
to tell me whether you're bullish or
bearish about it and a little bit of an
explanation why
fabulous qr code menus
what what for track and trace or for
reading the menu
for being in a restaurant qr code menus
yeah
bear good uh absolutely unnecessary
level of complexity
and means what restaurant has ever given
you a menu
that's two inches wide and four inches
deep for [ __ ] sake
[Laughter]
it's all the rage in dubai out here and
there's a number of different ways do
you have it in a single feed like an
infinite scroll thing
do you have it across multiple tabs do
you have photos of the food if you have
photos of the food you gotta scroll for
longer
are you do you allow people to order on
the browser do you allow do you have to
wave the waiter over
it's very very beautiful things about it
one there is a heuristic
that only fast food joints have
photographs of food for some reason okay
now logically you'd always have
photographs of food on the menu okay to
prevent you ordering something that you
hated the look of when it arrived
but there's a heuristic that men use a
textual in
market joints you know it's okay for kfc
to have a photo it's okay for mcdonald's
to have a photo
um but you don't do that you know the
manual cap say something right here
and so the qr code menu would allow you
to look at photographs
i would also argue that you might
um but then once you any large group of
people this doesn't really work and the
qr code menu in a large group of people
is going to be a flaming disaster
because
all it takes is one person to be
technologically incompetent the whole
process of ordering you've got a big
bottleneck there right next to the next
bull or bad
next bull or bear sex robots um
that comes with me slightly in the
category of things like anti-masking
which i don't fully understand
um and um but i think to some degree one
has to be
short term i think i think the best
diffusion curve is going to reach a
ceiling
fairly low because apartments where do i
put the thing my cleaning lady
right okay i mean unless someone invents
some really clever way in which right
i mean dude my clean lady is pretty
tolerant you know i occasionally walk
around the place in my underpants but i
think she'd draw the line in a sex robot
well that was the advantage of the
fleshlight wasn't it that the fleshlight
could be
hidden away as a flashlight that was the
whole point of it
but shy of being able to tumble your sex
doll up into a suitcase
which also if your cleaning lady finds
is going to cause more downstream
complications
yeah i mean grief you know no i i'm
going to say
i'm bullish but but i don't think i i
think it's going to reach an asymptote
of market penetration
which is an awful word to use in the
context um you know
at around the kind of 10 10 15 percent
level i don't
i don't i don't think i i don't think
i'll ever have a sex robot well i don't
never say that but it strikes me as
slightly implausible
okay uh next one smoking and vaping
uh a long term bearish on
uh smoking bullish on vaping i think i
i one of my most uh heinous views
is i think there are benefits to
nicotine uh mental and other benefits
which we will eventually acknowledge if
people stop being quite so
kind of manikin about everything uh it
isn't the nicotine that's harmful about
smoking it's the other [ __ ] that's
what's unusual in alcohol
it's the alcohol that's the problem the
bit that gives you the fun
is also the problem in smoking the bit
that gives you that whatever mental
you know capacity it is isn't the thing
that does most of the harm
got you uh fast fast i'm very i'm
actually very bullish on nicotine
yeah polish on nicotine overall it's the
delivery mechanism that's the problem
yeah uh so fast fashion basically will
it become unfashionable to wear fast
fashion because it kills polar bears and
sweatshop workers
or does it not matter when it's four
pounds of skirt
uh it i hate to say this but um
uh the the tragedy of fast fashion um
is that um this is the tragedy of fast
fashion okay
logical mid-market fashion
you know what you might call marks and
spencer's clothing or jaeger's just gone
into administration that's pretty up
market
but it's mid-market up market mid market
okay
the problem they have is you get an
endorphin rush from a bargain and you
get an endorphin rush from
um an extravagance but you don't get an
endorphin rush from mid-market retail
so i always have this problem that
something i can wear once that costs a
tenner
i'm getting quite a lot of kick for not
much money
right uh you know if you go on i'm
supposed to be i've started buying
things from asos now i don't treat them
as fast fashion
but i've started buying things like
trousers because no one cares about
trousers do they for whatever reason
it's the worst area for other than jeans
where some people buy those really weird
things with a
odd pattern on the arse okay other than
sort of
i don't own any denim i i'm a turtle
denim denier very bearish i don't know
i i don't know i'm not bearish because
it seems to be
it's it's very lindy as talent would say
and it survived a hell of a lot of you
know changes in fashion i just don't
understand it as a fabric why would i
wear an uncomfortable you know fabric
that's not
you know that fades unpleasant what's
the trouser of choice then is it sort of
more of a chino
like a comfortable chino material yeah
as you get older of course the elastic
waistband
suddenly arises extraordinary appeal
there but i mean of course under video
conferencing conditions
um our freedom in the trouser department
has gone up massively because
i i've got a theory that if women didn't
exist and if social convention didn't
exist
um most british men would wear shorts
every day
that's my life that's what my life is
like because i'm not accountable to
people for the way that i dress
right final final one only fans bull or
bear
only for only fans so it's the
direct to consumer
adult actress or actor platform which is
blowing up quite a lot in america at the
moment so it's decentralized the earning
potential
for either amateur or professional
actors and actresses
i'm not sure if you've seen this if you
haven't then i've just introduced you to
only for the
film industry kind of it's a little bit
like
it's a little bit like patreon but yes
but it's for people that do porny stuff
um very interesting you have seen that
guy from bolton who rings up the woman
on babe whatever it is babe cabin
biscuits are you drinking yeah what
biscuits are you eating yeah yeah yeah i
i
find those unbelievably funny
i love i love that kind of context um
i i once when i was a student i went to
see emmanuel at the local cinema
in in around the corner because it was
on at 10 o'clock at night we were all
very bored and my friend who's a massive
civil aviation fan
you may remember that emmanuel has sex
on the plane as she flies out to
where the hell is it it's somewhere in
southeast asia isn't it
and um my friend was absolutely incensed
because he said it's completely the
wrong sound effect for a boeing 747
um okay
so for as long as these actors and
actresses can keep the quality
i really enjoy the bit of pawn over it i
don't like porn actually very much i
mean
i can't claim that i don't watch it ever
because that'd be ridiculous everybody's
had a look
right but i find the bits of porn where
no sex is taking place
vaguely interesting because here you can
see the mental workings of someone who
has to contrive a back story okay
and that's narrative and it's
interesting the actual act itself
is actually unbelievably repetitive and
tedious well it would be like watching
it would be exactly the same as getting
cristiano ronaldo and saying right mate
before
you go out to play football what i
really want to see you do
is have a crack at this particular
orchestral piece on the violin and then
bake me a cake
and i'm going to watch you try and do
both of those things and then you can go
and crack on with the stuff that you're
capable of
the only ism is obviously good news
because it reduces the problem
i i i'd love to know more about the
economics of the adult entertainment
industry as i think they call themselves
because obviously they were if you think
about it they were advanced in terms of
payment mechanisms
online uh they were hugely advanced in
terms of online video streaming and now
what
this is is effectively they were online
advanced in terms of video conferencing
okay
so they generally discover technologies
about 10 years before businesses do
this decentralized nature is absolutely
insane i had both
a porn star who has been long time in
the adult industry and now gone to this
decentralized model and also a girl who
started
the uk's version of only fans and
generated 10 million pounds of revenue
in 16 months
so this particular model is
there's a lot to be said about it but
yeah i will i'll send you i'll send you
some very pc links where you can have a
look at
some some data that i've got about that
um
it is absolutely good because it
prevents the carousel effect
well there's never a subject the cruiser
effect is what happened
so before the gramophone came along okay
you could make a reasonable living
as the fifth best operatic tenor in
denmark
because you know there are enough opera
houses for you know and occasionally the
best two
operatic tenors were engaged or ill or
went down with a cold
and you got to sing a bit and you could
actually survive
caruso came along it's a winner takes
all effect for the gramophone
okay and everybody wanted caruso
not necessarily because he was the best
person of the time but simply because he
was the most famous so you get these
matthew effects
positive feedback effects and so caruso
ends up a billionaire
and the fifth best operatic tenor in
denmark loses his job sweeping the
street
so there is something really really
interesting because the same thing not
only in porn the same thing will happen
in the public speaking industry
how will it go will you have a caruso
effect where basically
if you're tony blair you get a million
quid to appear on zoom and if you're me
you get two pounds 57
you know or or will it go the opposite
way which is only fans
where i'm supported in my retirement on
patreon
occasionally appearing and talking to
people about behavioral science now i'll
tell you one really important thing by
the way
in terms of this is the most zoom is as
important as the internet
in terms of economic effects okay both
good and bad and they'll be complex
but i really believe that and i'll tell
you one very simple reason why the
washing machine was possibly more
important than the internet because it
allowed women to enter the workforce
okay when you took away the drudgery of
maintaining a middle-class home
it massively increased the the number of
people who could enter their workforce
um the only reason i think most people
retire from white collar jobs
is because they're sick of commuting
it's not because they're sick of work
i'm an accountant it's implausible as it
may seem really like doing accountancy
right because they're good at it and
actually a 63 year old accountant's
probably pretty damn good
right okay the only reason they retire
is because were not because they don't
like work but
the opportunity cost of work which is if
you have to be in a specific place in a
specific time and you have to travel to
get there
that price is too high it's not the time
you spend working it's the fact you
can't retire to the south of france
you can't go on a golfing holiday in you
know march when the flights are cheap
it's all that [ __ ] that causes people to
retire it's not the fact they don't like
work
what's the biggest lesson that you've
learned from observing 2020
um oh undoubtedly network effects
the fact that in order for zoom which is
when you think about it
blindingly [ __ ] obvious as a business
technology the fact that it took
everybody to be forced to use it at the
same time before its value became
apparent
shows actually an extraordinary lack of
vision
in our adoption of technology so in my
defense
i'd mandated zoom fridays my team before
the pandemic even hit because i said
look
this is a synchronous technology
therefore we all have to
um get stay home on the same day of the
week in order to make use of it
and a year and a half ago we started
discovering really weird things like you
can win business over zoom easy
you can't win business over email you've
got to have a meeting okay
but over zoom you can actually pick up
business you can you can deliver
business over zoom obviously you can't
deliver
no one's going to pay you a five-figure
sum to write a deck and then email it to
them
right okay so in the previous world
you'd have
to fly now you know uh
that makes you a kind of joint venture
with british airways you know if your
clients
if you're you know if you're my age
you're not very keen on going in economy
and
you know the clients on another
continent that essentially means that
you know half your profits going in
travel costs as it were
and so there's something very very
interesting about this and also because
business business exchange
there was no normal mode other than
going to the pub after a meeting
or going out for a meal there was no
informal means of business to business
communication
okay so businesses themselves were
optimized around coffee shops and
corridors where you had blackboard so
people could enjoy serendipitous
encounters
when you look at b2b communication it
was either incredibly cold and textual
it was like email or a text message or a
powerpoint deck or a
you know or a spreadsheet more likely
okay
or it was face-to-face which was hugely
expensive and time-consuming
and you could only face doing three of
those a week and what what it was been
like having a weird world where you had
like
limousines and you had buses
but you had nothing in between you know
what i mean
you didn't have private cars and this
the fact that business communication has
become
my volume of email has halved and most
of my email now is just about arranging
zoom calls
and marshall mcluhan would say zoom is a
warm or hot form of communication
whereas other than face to face all the
other business forms of communication
were cold
so this actually i find it much better
because you can actually go off at a
tangent on a zoom call
it makes things much less left-brained i
think i think it's a huge gift
good uh boris calls you up tomorrow and
says rory mate i'm struggling here
behaviorally how can we improve the
public's view of kovid restrictions
what do you say i don't know yet and i'm
still
puzzling because i think it's possible
to keep the disease in abundance
with some very simple heuristic rules
which obey
we they need to be visible in their
breaking so it needs to be visible when
people break them
okay um what's that mean what like
i do um i'm generally pro mask wearing
on the grounds that it seems to make
sense and i also
believe the theory of monika gandhi that
there's a certain
um variation effect to mask wearing
which is if you become minorly infected
with a small dose of covid
the likely outcome is not that you
become severely ill it's that you become
immune with minor ill effects
so i think masks work twice not just by
preventing infection but by reducing the
initial dose
um but bear in mind this is not not a
universally held belief and i'll
probably get kicked off twitter if i say
i'm not sure but i i generally believe i
think there might be a double win
in that respect i also think masters
benefit other people as well as you so
there's a double win in that
sense so if you look at those dimensions
masks might be working in eight
different ways rather than just one and
by doing that it's quite obvious when
someone breaks
my neighbor in fulham her next her
upstairs neighbor and the flat above
basically held a party for eight people
uh the night before last now here's an
awkward thing in a country like britain
what do you do you don't dub on your
neighbor
okay right it's this is this is like
east germany and even she who doesn't
like her neighbor very much
goes okay my relationship would be
impossible if i were known to have
dobbed on my neighbor and rung the
police
um so you need some degree of voluntary
compliance and among the young that's
disproportionately difficult because
they don't you know they don't really
perceive much risk
and i don't know quite what to do there
but i think it'll be possible to close
certain mass events
and to have um some sort of
we don't know the extent to which
private parties are actually causing the
hot spots and i think it might be quite
high
so maybe what you want to do is get
people out it's actually banned parties
at home
and open pubs under under stringent
conditions
or create outdoor spaces
it looks like the rate of outdoor
transmission is pretty tiny to be honest
um there are also things about
ventilation which nobody's investigating
there are also things about sprays and
ultraviolet light which nobody seems to
have investigated
so i think the mask is important because
it acts as the bottleneck
of transmission okay which is the mouth
and nose
we don't seem to have the level of
contact based transmission that people
anticipated either do we
and bunch i mean we would have noticed
if postman had started getting very ill
or something like that
um but
i
uh it's a really interesting question
and i i think we should look at
ventilation i think we should look at uh
sprays and um viruses and also air
filters
uh indoors and we should also look at um
uh you know obviously masks ventilation
and ultraviolet light and other other
uh virus idle things so not just the
mask
it seems a bit weird that we focus
purely on hand washing and masks and
haven't investigated uh you know sprays
which can kill viruses quite effectively
uh well what else i mean i'm a bit
sympathetic with the government
the reason for that is the only people
who seem to know exactly what we should
have done
are all working in journalism you know
journalists
seem to have a ludicrous idea about how
simple this is and how
you know it was obvious we should have
locked down early actually it looked
like the rate of infection was already
falling before lockdown was imposed
simply because of voluntary measures for
instance and in london
places the absence of tourism you see
would have been highly significant
so i mean you know it's incredibly
difficult what the show said what this
shows in total
is that we're used to the pretense
of knowing what we're doing okay now i
don't think we know what we're doing
most of the time but most of the time we
have a discipline like economics
which allows us to pretend we know
what's going on
and so we can post rationalize lots of
outcomes
and that allows the kind of scientific
brigade to become overconfident
this is genuinely a case where
okay we will know in about two years
time what we should have done
in defense of any government i mean the
belgian government the french government
the irish government right
i mean there may be things like germany
had a very bad flu season
okay the uk didn't now
those things can actually affect
susceptibility going forward
so we look at the germans and we
naturally assume that's because of it's
like racism actually
because they're highly competent but the
austrians similarly had
you know very very um light switzerland
weirdly has now become very severe in
the second wave okay
so first of all we often make total
generalizations about countries and
and based on national stereotypes you
know
uh where we no i mean actually i think
greece had a fairly light covered thing
but no
greeks incredibly bright people but
nobody ever says we should look at the
greek model
okay because that's just not what you do
um a very very good medics actually uh
generally so so one of the interesting
things is that there's an awful lot of
national stereotyping going on and
there's an awful lot of
generalization going on we're typically
looking at things at a national level
which may not even be the helpful way to
look at things at all maybe we should
have localized more
but i i just want to know if anyone has
got a solution to that fact of how you
stop your neighbor having
your younger neighbor having a party
under lockdown without dubbing them to
the cops
um uh strikes me as a really interesting
question now the first phase of lockdown
you can do that because simple social
stigma would be enough
but that's getting increasingly
difficult and i generally don't i i mean
my view is that you know at some point
we'll we'll know what we should have
done
probably it might even be a year and a
half two years
because they're really weird things why
is switzerland having a big second wave
suddenly
um uh you notice huge discrepancy
between say oman and the united arab
emirates
um certain certain countries new zealand
of course had the benefit of getting it
laid
and it's a bloody island in the middle
of nowhere so we're going isn't the new
zealand government brilliant well
yeah they are brilliant okay they did it
very well
but they had opportunities which other
people didn't
um so it's kind of you know it's kind of
complex
the other thing by the way is that if
you lock down it's worth remembering
that if you lock down too soon and
people don't have enough time to prepare
for it you end up with a lot of people
breaking the rules
right you know if you basically said
right we're locking down at midnight
tonight
you would have ended up with mayhem on
the roads with everybody who was at
their
london place trying to get to their
holiday home everybody who was separated
from their spouse trying to get back
home
you know so at some point you have to
actually have a delay for behavioral
reasons not for epidemiological reasons
yeah so this [ __ ] is not [ __ ] easy
because you're at the intersection
between ethics
i mean i think we should have done more
deliberate infection experiments
actually on the young
not not i mean not not in the very early
stages but but
i i don't think you know i think some
some challenge trials
um you know a few months ago would have
made sense actually to understand more
about the
the because we know because it's
asymptomatic for the early stages we
know very little about the early stages
of development
and what separates out a an illness with
severe outcomes to an illness with
trivial outcomes
why do you think people are prepared to
pay 10 times or 100 times the price of a
book
for a course on the same subject i've
been fascinated by this recently so
a lot of inter internet entrepreneurs
are creating a course of how to have the
perfect
this or how to do your how to do how to
do habit setting and goal settings a
very popular online course
where people are prepared to charge 100
200
300 pounds and add a community on the
side and yet you can get atomic habits
by james clear
for a tenner yeah
it's a bit of an espresso effect i
suspect because when you frame something
in the field of education
i can remember at work occasionally i'd
buy a book for the team
or you know a behavioral science book
and i'd claim it out of the training
budget that was considered actually a
bit of a you know i'm not sure you can
do that
i said it's a book it's [ __ ] training
right
why is it okay to claim for some person
to come in and talk to us all
but it's not okay to buy buy everybody a
book potentially from the person who was
giving the talk even
and yeah absolutely and there'll be more
in there but it's not like when i wrote
as far as i know when i wrote my book i
was not aware of saying well i'm gonna
hold back on these five things because
they're far more monetizable if i give a
talk or a training
course it's not like you hold back in
your book you give everything you put
everything into your book you possibly
can
and hope it's enough to warrant the
length which it really is i mean
a hell of a lot of books to be honest
tail off towards the end you know
there's a bit of barrel scraping going
on
to get it across the 80 000 word mark
right
um but i yeah i've never understood that
to be absolutely honest have you noticed
it did you know that the particular
sort of effect that i'm talking about
synchronicity has a value the fact that
we're doing something along other along
with other people
seems to have a value that we have
portioned some emotional value too
the fact that we're doing something with
other people um
the part of it is that the richard
thaler experiment about bear you know
what i mean
where he said you're on a beach you've
been parched with him it's very famous
experiment in behavioral science and
um you're a bear you're on a beach
you're getting pretty thirsty because
you've been on a hot beach for the last
three hours and your mate says
okay i've noticed a place along the
beach
that sells chilled bottles of heineken
right
okay tell me how much you're willing to
pay for a bottle of refrigerated
heineken
and if the price is below your maximum
willingness to pay
okay i'll buy you a bottle and bring it
back right
now the point about the along the beach
is that you're not enjoying the ambiance
of the place selling it
if you say shaq selling chilled heineken
this is in the 1990s or earlier
maybe in the 80s people were willing to
pay something like 1.59 for a bottle of
chilled beer
if you describe the place as a boutique
hotel
they actually um were prepared to pay
2.40
or something like this bear in mind
you've got to adjust for inflation so
it's like
5 or 2.80 or something like that you
know
now what's weird about that the utility
they drive for the consumption of the
beer which is the branded beer and
refrigerator in both cases is identical
but they accept that given the overheads
of a boutique hotel relative to the
overheads of a shack
you should be prepared to pay more so
there may be a degree of labor component
to it which is
look the bar we all know that the
marginal cost of a book is zero
um whereas okay this course is actually
involving
effort on your path is taking up your
time
um so my my thought on it the reason
that i
propose people are prepared to pay so
much more 10 times 100 times the price
of a book for a course that achieves the
same thing
is that people are concerned with
outcomes
rather than rather than they are with
the process of going through it
if you were to tell me or tell anyone so
what you're saying is the course gives
you a bit of
paper that says you completed the course
no more that
because you can't put on your cv i read
it i read it i read
alchemy no it's more that um what people
read specifically in the
self-development or non-fiction world
the reason they read
partly is for the enjoyment of reading
the book but more so for the outcome and
the new life that they think they're
going to be able to achieve
with the insights from rory sutherland's
alchemy or james clay's atomic habits
and by taking the course what i think
that they presume they're going to
achieve
is more likely more compliant more
effective outcomes
so you're paying for the new world that
you're going to enter
and the presumption is that by taking
the course your outcomes are more
assured
is that because i i mean it might be
that you're paying for the course as a
commitment device
perhaps yeah costly which is that you
really will fill it
i mean because i was talking about this
with gusto which is that
we there's the classic example i give is
my financial advisor
you know i pay him a whole shed load of
cash for stuff i could theoretically do
myself
but i'm realistic enough to know that i
probably won't do it left to my own
devices if
my wife starts talking about my pension
i basically go into a narcoleptic
coma okay out of sheer tedium after
about five seconds
whereas if this bloke comes around and i
paid him a shed load of cash
i feel i really do have to act on what
he's done so we might be actually
spending the money to signal to
ourselves
that might be another part of it as well
last thing last
last question rory uh you say to be
brilliant you have to be irrational
what's that mean
oh that you nearly all really just to
give an example from the field of
entrepreneurialism
nearly all disproportionately successful
businesses
are disproportionately successful
not despite of but because of some
seemingly irrational or nonsensical
component in their offering
so um the argument would be that um
most people have a post-rationalized
sense-making narrative of how a business
works and what's important
okay which is almost certainly wrong in
some dimensions
and so if you the example i always give
the most extreme case of this is dyson
okay if and i admit this of myself that
if james dyson had come to me in the
1980s or
1990s and he said i think there's a
market for a 700 pound vacuum cleaner
okay i would say well let's have a look
at the market shall we do a bit of
market scoping and let's do a bit of
market research
and if i'd ask people would you pay 700
pounds for a vacuum cleaner answers
would have varied between i don't think
so to [ __ ] off
um and if i'd looked at the existing
vacuum cleaner market i would have seen
that miele was
it was a grudge purchase it was a
distress purchase nobody enjoyed buying
a vacuum cleaner
you know you had a meal at around 250
quid you probably had a henry at around
80 or 100 or 110 or whatever they are
maybe maybe the meal stretched to 300
but you basically go
okay jim look don't give up the day job
and then if james had turned back to you
and said but wait you haven't heard
about my 400 pound hairdryer
you would have had him escorted out of
the building okay
and so what i'm saying is that um
conventional marketing approaches
probably encourage us to produce
products that are kind of
okay but the point is people have
already solved
people aren't interested in okay because
they've already solved the problems that
okay
solves what they haven't solved is the
problems that weird solves
and so you know though you know the the
uber map is an example of what i call
psychologic it's ingenious because it
doesn't
increase the speed at which your car
turns up but it massively reduces the
pain we experience in
uncertainty while waiting for it to
arrive you know
and i think uh you know there are huge
huge things you could do
um huge things you could do which would
effectively make it possible
we don't have metrics for the human
emotions and so we're trying to improve
human emotional state
by optimizing things which don't really
correlate
neatly at all you know we're trying to
optimize speed and time and cost and
distance and all these things
so hs2 um right we're trying to optimize
an engineering problem as though it will
solve a human emotional problem or
behavioral problem
but we don't have metrics for the things
that matter we don't have a metric for
uncertainty we don't have
we're not even measuring with high speed
to the end-to-end journey right
because i've made the point repeatedly
that you could increa enormously
reduce the journey time from london to
manchester
not by actually making the train faster
but by having a service where if i've
booked a pre-booked ticket to manchester
and there are empty seats on the train
20 and 40 minutes beforehand
i can book one of the earlier tickets
right if you let me do that
okay you can reduce the journey time to
manchester and increase capacity
because it's better yield management
it's better load balancing of journeys
if you allow people to go early don't
let people go later
if you miss your train stuff stuff it
you can pay more a lot you know you pay
full fare
but if you said actually that you know
they're 50 empty seats in first class
and the train that leaves 40 minutes
before your train
if you pay as a fiver you can jump on
one of those right
virgin makes money i save journey time
hanging around burger king for 40
minutes and
you know at houston right everybody wins
costs 500
000 to develop the app instead they're
spending 60 billion on the sonic trains
because they're measuring the wrong
bloody things i like the time on the
train
most mancunians don't want high speed
too because they're fine with things as
they are
and the reason is that most people don't
travel to london often enough
that they you know a let's say a sort of
i don't know what it is i guess it's a
40
reduction in journey time or 30
reduction time journey time
just doesn't make that much [ __ ]
difference the point that you made about
uber it's one that i've heard you make
before have you heard of telio
anticipation now teleo is as in
teleological
yes correct it's go goal-based
anticipation and we find it painful do
we
yeah so very much as you know about the
way that uber works or the way that
uh disneyland works so they say 10
minutes from this point five minutes
from this point
it's not necessarily about the weight
it's about the ability to anticipate
but telio anticipation was a term coined
by
hans volkart ulmer to describe our
knowledge of how an eventual end point
influences the entirety of the
experience
and he used endurance sports as the
medium so researchers in the field have
probed what happens
when you hide the finish line
surreptitiously move it or take it away
entirely so there's this
very famous backyard race which you
might be familiar with where
uh they have to run 4.16 miles every
hour
which is like 100 100 miles per
24 hours but the point is that they just
keep going until
everybody stops until the last person is
standing
so there's no end to this endurance
event they just run this
loop and run this loop and run this loop
is that us running over rory is that
your name i think that is
that's probably so if there's probably
someone panic that is absolutely
fascinating
because if you think about it we knew
about that tell your anticipation thing
if you look at that photograph of bob
dylan waiting for the oust ferry
in yeah i need to be on the next call
okay rory you'll see brilliantly
alongside the car queue
okay i'll leave you i better leave you
now i'm sorry about this no worries see
that's right rory thank you brother